Even the most seemingly invincible bad guys
usually succumb to the hero by the end of the
movie, but the rare occasions they don't can
make for a memorable experience. Be warned:
We're digging into spoilers galore in the
best movies where villains win in the end.
A story with roots in history, The
Crucible takes place way back at the
end of the 17th century in colonial America in
the sleepy town of Salem, Massachusetts. Yep,
that Salem. Inspired by the Salem
Witch Trials of historic legend,
the film follows a group of young
women, including Abigail Williams,
played by Winona Ryder, who has had an affair
with Daniel Day-Lewis's John Proctor and literally
wants to put a curse on his wife in order to
kill her off and have Proctor all to herself.
Already messed up in the special kind of way
that only real-life scenarios can provide,
the situation begins to spin out of control when
Abigail and the group of girls are nearly caught
practicing witchcraft and ultimately begin
to accuse others to save their own skin.
Of course, taking place in Puritan New England,
these kinds of things were not taken lightly, and
anyone who is accused by the supposedly innocent
posse of girls has to either confess or be
executed. The film ends with several characters,
including John Proctor himself, refusing
to confess and ultimately being killed. Talk
about a depressing win for the forces of evil.
Unlike a lot of horror flicks, the triumph
of Saw's villain comes as a clever surprise.
Whether you're a fan of the franchise or not, it's
hard not to be impressed by the twist ending that
the first film in the series delivered, with
Jigsaw rising up from the center of the room,
bringing everyone's jaws crashing to the ground.
While director James Wan's debut film was a
horrifying success, that doesn't change the fact
that the villain yet again wins without question.
One of the first revelations of the film
is that the saws so helpfully provided to
the captive protagonists are
meant for cutting not metal,
but flesh. The climax becomes increasingly tense
as Dr. Lawrence Gordon, played by Cary Elwes,
slowly loses his mental stability. But even
before the saws come into play, the string of
events orchestrated by the mysterious murderer
are more than enough to showcase that this
is a villain who knows how to win. From bear
traps to barbed wire and more, Jigsaw is one
of the most successful villains to ever lay
in a pool of fake blood on a bathroom floor.
The early 1970s were a dark
time for American movies,
and Chinatown is exemplary of that trend. The
film is stylized like a noir, complete with a
1930s setting and a complicated plot involving
water rights in California. The movie's plot
is ultimately fairly secondary to its tone, which
is despairing throughout. In its final moments,
we see the death of the film's heroine played by
Faye Dunaway, and hear the film's signature line:
"Forget it Jake, it's Chinatown."
The film's villain, Noah Cross, played by John
Huston, gets away with his complicated scheme
to consolidate more power. What's more, no
one discovers that his daughter, who was
the one who initially opened the case with Jack
Nicholson's private investigator character Jake
Gittes , was someone he had abused practically
all her life. At the film's conclusion,
Gittes fails to protect her and is forced to
walk away from the whole affair unsatisfied.
Chinatown is a grim film about the realities
of life -- where a few powerful people can
play with the rest of us like pieces on a chess
board. Gittes tries his best to change things,
but discovers that knowing the truth
matters less than having power.
The Coen brothers don't usually make happy
movies, but No Country for Old Men is one
of the filmmaking duo's bleakest. It
follows Josh Brolin's Llewelyn Moss
as he makes off with a huge pile of cash
in the aftermath of a drug deal gone wrong.
He's pursued by Javier Bardem's Anton Chigurh,
a man relentlessly bent on recovering the funds.
Chigurh is a menacing figure -- who can
forget the infamous coin flip scene?"
"Call it."
"Call it?"
"Yes."
"For what?"
"Just call it."
Both Moss and Chigurh are also being
pursued by Tommy Lee Jones' character,
Sheriff Tom Bell, who makes a vow to
protect Moss but ultimately fails.
Chigurh kills him offscreen, recovers the
money, and walks away scot free. No Country
for Old Men ends with Bell, who has retired from
the force as a result of the violence he's seen,
as he describes a dream he once had about
his father and finding light in the darkness.
That ending, and the entirety of No Country for
Old Men, suggests that light is an illusion.
Humanity lives in the darkness and revels in it,
and bad people do bad things and get away with
them. Anton Chigurh isn't punished for his crimes.
He's brutal enough to do whatever he wants.
Rosemary's Baby follows Mia Farrow as Rosemary,
as she goes through her pregnancy and the birth
of her child, only to discover that she's
delivered a child of Satan. The baby was part
of a deal that her husband drew up with their
neighbors, who happen to worship the devil.
Throughout the film, Rosemary works to uncover
what's really going on with her pregnancy,
but in the end, she fails to stop the demonic
scheme. What's more, she seems to decide that
she's willing to love the child anyway. She was
forced into this pregnancy against her will,
sold out by her husband
completely. Her child, though,
is still hers, even if his dad
is a bit of a troublesome figure.
The movie ends on the bleak idea that Rosemary
can't do anything about her situation.
She's been tortured throughout the film, and her
reward is a child she never asked for. Evil wins
out, and Rosemary is left to pick up the pieces
of a life that other people have forced on her.
If your wife tried to frame you for her killing
her, would you take her back when she returned?
Most people would likely say no, but not Ben
Affleck's Nick Dunn, one of the characters at
the center of Gone Girl. The movie follows Nick
in the aftermath of his wife's disappearance,
as evidence begins to pile up suggesting he's
the killer. As we learn midway through the film,
though, his wife Amy, played by Rosamund
Pike, has been setting him up the entire time.
From there, the movie tracks
Amy's decision to return home,
and her ultimate plan to trap
Nick in their relationship.
She's pregnant with his child, and he
decides that he has to stay to help raise it.
As Amy, the film's ostensible villain, tells
him, he actually likes the life she gives him.
She's exciting and challenging,
and that's what he wants,
even if it means that he's occasionally
accused of murder. In the end of Gone Girl,
Amy gets everything that she wants, even though
she's killed at least one person along the way.
Few movies pull the rug out from audiences
as successfully as The Usual Suspects.
For most of its runtime, we think
we're getting a reliable version of
the film's events from Kevin Spacey's Verbal Kint,
the only survivor of a five-man crew who decides
to pull a robbery that goes terribly awry.
In the film's final moments, though, we realize
that Verbal has been lying the entire time.
The film's villain, a terrible
criminal known only as Keyser Soze,
is actually Kint, and the limp he's had for
the entire movie is fake. It's unclear how much
truth there is in the story that Kint tells,
but he ultimately escapes without a scratch.
He deceives everyone, and the movie's
final moments are devoted to watching
Kint drive away, having killed several
people without any sort of punishment.
Spacey's performance in the film won
him an Oscar, and it's easy to see why.
There's a menace hiding underneath the
supposedly vulnerable Kint that becomes
obvious as soon as you know the twist. Kint is
just telling a story to get out of a tough bind,
and the cops who are listening
fall for it hook, line, and sinker.
Erotic thrillers thrive on the bizarre
combination of sensual tension and death threats.
In Basic Instinct, Sharon Stone and Michael
Douglas balance those qualities perfectly.
The film follows Douglas' erratic cop as
he becomes obsessed with Stone's character,
an author who is a suspect in a
homicide case in part because she
wrote a book that describes a very
similar killing in gruesome detail.
Douglas' obsession eventually transforms into a
romantic relationship, and audiences are never
explicitly told that Stone's character is guilty.
Even so, it's easy to put the pieces together and
realize that she's likely gotten away with several
killings over the course of the film — possibly
before as well. All of that becomes more
evident in the film's closing moments,
as we see that Stone's author has
considered killing Douglas' cop
using the same method as in the
death at the start of the film.
Basic Instinct is a filthy neo-noir
in every sense of the word.
While we don't know for sure
who the murderer really is,
it certainly seems like someone has gotten
off easy as the movie reaches its conclusion.
The Alien movies are generally fairly
bleak affairs. In the first couple,
though, protagonist Ellen Ripley gets out of
danger by the end, even if there are heavy
casualties along the way. By the time Ridley
Scott got around to directing Alien: Covenant,
that had changed. Unlike most previous Alien
movies, though, the villain of Covenant isn't
a xenomorph, but an android named David, played
by Michael Fassbender, who was first introduced
in the preceding film, Prometheus. In this movie,
we learn that David is the xenomorph's creator,
and we watch as he slowly picks off the
crew of the ship that has discovered him.
Although several crew members do survive the
film, David undoubtedly emerges victorious,
and successfully escapes the planet where he was
stranded. He's going to spread xenomorphs all over
the galaxy, and one of those very same aliens
will eventually terrorize Ripley and her crew
on the Nostromo. David's victory in this
film is not just bleak because of what it
means about Covenant, but also because of what it
foretells about the rest of the Alien universe.
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
is about a rebel who loses.
The film stars Jack Nicholson as Randall
McMurphy, a new patient at a mental institution
who pleaded insanity in order to avoid hard
labor while imprisoned. Once he arrives,
he discovers that the hospital is being run
under the strict supervision of Nurse Ratched,
and decides that he wants to challenge
her rule. The film chronicles McMurphy's
attempts to rile the other patients at the
institute up in defiance of Nurse Ratched.
"It's a long fly ball to deep left center
- it's going, it's going, it's gone!"
Ultimately, though, McMurphy's attempts at
defiance fail. At the end of One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest, it's determined that the only
way the threat McMurphy poses can be neutralized
is if he is lobotomized. In the film's final
scene, Chief, a character who is believed
to be non-verbal throughout most of the film -
only to be revealed to be basically faking it,
asphyxiates McMurphy with a pillow and
escapes from the institute. Although
Chief gets away with his life, McMurphy,
the rebel at the film's center, does not.
Nurse Ratched quashes his attempt to get
himself and his fellow patients more freedom,
and he dies. Ratched's tyrannical
rule over the facility remains.
The Cabin in the Woods is something
of an exception on this list.
The villains undoubtedly win, but they do so
with the help of the movie's protagonists.
The Cabin in the Woods is an explicit riff
on horror movie tropes, as five friends head
to the country to spend a weekend in a creepy,
abandoned cabin. What they don't know is that they
are actually human sacrifices in an annual ritual.
The ritual has specific rules that happen to align
with those of a horror movie, and requires that at
least four of the five friends die in the cabin.
If the friends don't die, mythical forces from
the underworld will return to Earth and wipe
out mankind. When the main characters discover
this, though, they decide not to play along.
Instead of agreeing to act as
sacrifices, they decide that humanity
should be doomed. The ritual fails, and
the titans return to Earth. As a result,
the film's human villains, the people who were
trying to sacrifice our main characters, lose.
Watchmen is based on some pretty depressing
source material, and Zack Snyder's 2009
adaptation doesn't do much to mess with that
tone. Although the adaptation does change
some things, the basic plot of
the graphic novel remains intact:
The death of a superhero spurns
an investigation that ultimately
unveils a plot hatched by Matthew Goode's
Ozymandias, the smartest man on the planet.
Ozymandias' plan is to avert an apocalyptic event
by creating one on a much smaller scale. In the
movie, this event is a radioactive explosion
that he plans to blame on Dr. Manhattan,
uniting the U.S. and Soviet Union against him.
Ultimately, the rest of the superheroes agree
that Ozymandias' plan is the best course of
action if an apocalypse is to be avoided.
The plan requires the deaths of millions,
but it goes off without a hitch,
and Ozymandias believes that he'll be
justified in the end. Both the movie
and the graphic novel suggest that the plan may
not be the success that he imagines it to be,
but they allow him to carry it out anyway. He
wins, and his victory means death and destruction.
The original 1973 version of The Wicker
Man ends with a human sacrifice, as all
great horror movies should. The film follows
a devout Christian detective named Neil Howie
who visits a small Hebridean island as
part of his search for a missing girl.
While on the island, Howie becomes horrified
by the pagan rituals that he sees practiced.
Ultimately, he determines that the missing
girl is meant to be a human sacrifice,
and infiltrates the islanders'
ceremony in order to rescue her.
After escaping with her, though,
it's revealed that she was just a
ruse to draw Howie to the island. Howie was
always intended to be the human sacrifice,
as the sacrifice has to meet certain
criteria, and he meets all of them. The
movie ends with our hero detective being burned
alive alongside a variety of animal sacrifices.
Playing on the paranoia caused by terrorist
bombers in the 1990s, Arlington Road is about
suspecting that your neighbors are terrorists...
and ultimately finding out that you're right. The
movie follows Michael Faraday as he meets his new
neighbors and begins to suspect that they're lying
about their lives. Ultimately, he discovers
that they're part of a terrorist organization
and their goal is to blow up part of an FBI
building located near their neighborhood.
Although Michael attempts to warn the authorities
about the incoming attack, his neighbors are ahead
of him at every turn. Ultimately, a bomb does
go off, but the bomb has been planted in the
back of Michael's car. Because Michael was at
the FBI building to warn them, it blows part
of that building up, and Michael appears to be
the lone wolf responsible for the explosion.
Michael's neighbors, meanwhile, get away
scot free, and move to another suburb
where they can find someone else
to blame for their latest attack.
There aren't really any good guys in Ex Machina,
but that doesn't mean that the villain doesn't
ultimately win the day. The movie, which tells
the story of Domhnall Gleeson's low-level
computer programmer named Caleb who travels
to a tech billionaire's house in order to test
his advanced artificial intelligence, exists in a
moral gray area. Ava, the artificial intelligence,
seems kind and gentle, but obviously resents
the cage she has been placed in by her creator.
Eventually, Ava escapes that cage,
killing her billionaire creator
and trapping Caleb inside her former home. The
movie treats her escape with a sense of dread,
and although she sends some characters to their
doom, it's hard not to feel at least part of
yourself rooting for Ava. She's been trapped
by mankind for the entirety of Ex Machina,
and in the end, she finally
gets a chance to break free.
If you're just looking at its premise,
Inside Man really shouldn't work. The movie,
which tells the story of bank robbers
and the cops who are trying to stop them,
spends much of its running time hyping up
the genius of the robbery plot at its center.
At times, it seems like the head robber, played
by Clive Owen, is losing control of his carefully
constructed plan. And because the cop in charge
of stopping him is played by Denzel Washington,
it can be pretty hard to imagine
the robbery going successfully.
In the end, though, our robber gets
away with it. He hides inside the
bank for days after the initial robbery,
waiting for the right moment to casually
exit the building with all the money he's
stolen. It's a shockingly simple plan,
one that only requires some determination on his
part. Washington's cop steps away from the crime
realizing there's an entire rigged system that
he's operating within. At the end of the day,
Owen's character gets away with it because the
cop charged with stopping him stopped caring.
Mr. Glass, the villain at
the heart of Unbreakable,
believes in the archetypes that comic
books establish. He knows he's a villain,
and that David Dunn exists to oppose him. The
movie's twist isn't that Glass has pulled off
some major scheme. What we discover is that
he's been a terrorist this entire time,
and that his ultimate goal was to uncover
other people with special abilities like his.
Glass gets away with his plot because he carries
it out before the movie even really begins. He
discovers David in the process, and while David
ultimately imprisons him, he's actually doing
exactly what Glass wants him to. Glass's
only goal was to find a hero to oppose him,
and he's done that by discovering David. He
never wanted to escape from his plan without
consequences. He wants to fulfill his comic
book fantasy, with everything that might entail.
Matt Damon has a range he doesn't get to show
off much these days. In The Talented Mr. Ripley,
though, we see Damon play a psychopath with a
chilling skill. The movie follows Damon's Tom
Ripley, a low-class man who rises up the
ranks of young high society in the 1950s
thanks to a relationship with Jude Law's
Dickie Greenleaf, a wealthy, aimless young man.
Ultimately, Tom's love for and jealousy of Dickie
proves too powerful, and he kills him at sea.
Instead of confessing to his crime, though, Tom
takes over Dickie's life, and all of the wealth
that it entails. Tom spends the rest of the
film trying desperately not to get caught, and
he succeeds. He gets away with that murder — and
another one. Tom Ripley may not be a good person,
but he is very good at what he does, and he
proves that at the end of The Talented Mr. Ripley.
The Vanishing is an effective thriller because of
the toll it inflicts on a harmless protagonist.
The story follows a couple, Saskia and Rex, who
are on a trip together. When the two of them
pull over at a rest stop, Saskia goes into
the station to buy something and vanishes.
Rex frantically searches for her,
but is never able to find her.
Years later, Rex is confronted by Saskia's
kidnapper. Raymond, the man who kidnapped
and eventually killed Saskia, tells Rex that
he knew from a young age that he didn't have
any conscience. In fact, his decision
to kidnap Saskia came as he was trying
to determine whether doing bad things felt
any different to him than doing good deeds.
Eventually, he tells Rex that the only way he'll
be able to learn what happened to Saskia is by
experiencing it himself. The two return to the
rest stop where Saskia originally vanished,
and Raymond drugs Rex. When he wakes up,
Rex finds that Raymond has buried him alive.
Raymond, meanwhile, is living a
quiet, peaceful life with his family.
He's gotten away with killing two
people, and he doesn't feel a thing.
Satan is usually a hard villain to
overcome. That much is obvious in The Omen,
a classic horror film for many reasons, but one
is undoubtedly its bleak ending. The film tells
the story of a couple who unknowingly adopt
the antichrist, a young boy named Damien.
Robert Thorn, Damien's father, spends much of the
movie trying to determine where his adopted son
actually came from. Along the way, a number of
people die under questionable circumstances.
"Look at me Damien. It's all for you."
As the movie approaches its climax, Damien's
adopted mother is killed by his nanny,
and when Robert discovers that his wife has
been killed, he stabs the nanny to death.
Then, he takes Damien to a church and places
him on the altar, only to be shot down by police
before he can kill his demonic son. The movie
ends with a joint funeral for Damien's adopted
family, and Damien himself cracking a smile. By
the end of The Omen, evil has conquered good,
and everyone who knows what Damien really
is has already ended up in the ground.
When you watch Brazil, things are not exactly
what they seem. The movie follows a low-level
government worker named Sam who spends
much of his time thinking about a woman
who comes to him in dreams. Ultimately, Sam
becomes embroiled in a complicated conspiracy
after discovering that a bureaucratic error has
led to the arrest and death of the wrong man.
That discovery leads Sam down a path to find
the woman he's been seeing in his dreams,
who is named Jill. When he learns that Jill
is considered a terrorist accomplice because
she attempted to report the wrongful arrest,
Sam creates false records so she can escape.
After sharing a romantic night
together, the two are arrested,
and Sam is strapped to a chair where he is about
to be tortured. Before the torture can begin,
though, a resistance force breaks into
the building and rescues Sam and Jill.
In the movie's final moments, though,
we learn that the rescue mission was
all a delusion of Sam's broken mind.
We see that he is still trapped to the chair, and
it's heavily implied that he has been lobotomized.
Sam may dream of escaping the bureaucracy
that controls every aspect of his life,
but in reality, it's a system
that's impossible to escape from.
Another horror entry, Creep's ending is dark
and definitive. This found-footage film tells
the story of Aaron, a videographer who has
been hired by a man named Josef to film a
video diary in a remote cabin. Josef tells
Aaron that he has an inoperable brain tumor,
and wants to film a diary for his
daughter, who will be born after he dies.
Josef displays strange behavior throughout the
movie, and Aaron ultimately receives a call
from Josef's sister urging him to leave the
house as soon as possible. The two scuffle,
but Aaron gets away, and begins getting
videotapes from Josef following his departure.
Aaron realizes that Josef is stalking him, and
Josef eventually offers to meet Aaron in a public
park in order to make peace. As a precaution,
Aaron decides to keep a camera on himself.
Josef comes up from behind Aaron while he's
sitting on a bench and kills him with an axe.
Josef reviews the footage Aaron collected
following his death, and realizes that Aaron
must have thought he was a good person. The
movie ends as Josef moves on to his next kill,
and puts Aaron's film on the shelf
with the rest of his victims.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.